ma faim le toit des caps il a 27 ans et
ne parlent pas alexandra des parents
dévoués qui le rejoignent dans son monde
s'occupe de lui
et s'inquiète pour son avenir parce
qu'on vieillit g60 1 qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont arriver dans le futur qu'est ce qui
va arriver pour alexandre c'est pour
donner une voix et un toit aux adultes
autistes semi autonome qui ont besoin
d'un encadrement que véronique cloutier
et louis morissette ont choisi cette
cause il existe des maisons de répit des
ressources internes et d'un meilleur pas
d'hébergement permanent qui existent
quand ils ne peuvent plus vivre avec
leurs parents les adultes autistes se
retrouve en institution ou dans des
foyers qui sont mal adaptés à leurs
besoins
n'ayant pas d'enfants et d'adultes
autistes dans notre famille on écoute
beaucoup de gens autour de nous ce qu'on
veut faire c'est vraiment créé un
concept qu'on va être capable de
reproduire un petit peu partout au
québec et pourquoi au canada les
architectes ont traduit les besoins
sensorielle des personnes autistes
beaucoup d'argent mis en recherche
j'essayais de comprendre celle à
l'analyse pour le sont pour les
matériaux l'ailé des points de vue et
ils arrachaient chaussée sur le péage
choisir les résidents comment on va les
faire cohabiter parce qu'un au pied levé
dans le bruyant neuvième pole bruit y en
a qui aiment se coller yankees veulent
pas être dans la boue ont fait au retour
alors le réseau de la santé assurera les
soins et l'accès à la maison qui pourra
accueillir jusqu'à 20 résidants
c'est une nouvelle maison au nouveau
concept réfléchi avec les concepts de
2018 elle relaie recherche
ça va nous permettre aussi de documenter
cet aspect là le développement du
concept et la construction de la
première maison prévue pour décembre
prochain varennes coûteront un peu plus
de 4 millions de dollars nous manque
encore 3 millions mais on a décidé de
procéder quand même en france parce que
l'urgence d'âge et c'est un espoir pour
pour notre fils pour sa qualité de vie
c'est un milieu de vie donc c'est à ses
inspirations ses capacités
[Musique]
ici anne louise despatie radio canada
montréal
[Musique]